[Musique]
Jean la sal bonjour Nous vous
interviewons et nous allons vous
interroger pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle Serview on aurait aimé avoir
un petit peu votre opinion sur la
situation française tant économique que
social que tout un tas de choses on va
commencer par la situation sociale vous
revenez d'un tour de France d'environ
6000 km c'est ça vous avez marché
pendant 6000 km juste avant vous avez
fait une petite grve de la fin histoire
de d'assoir vos opinions et de faire
comprendre que vous étiez quelqu'un de
déterminé et j'ai même chanté un peu
vous avez chanté un petit peu oui
qu'est-ce que vous nous faites remonter
comme information au bout de 6000 km
autour de la France dans la France avec
les mers avec les les habitants de la
France qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce que les
Français vous vous ont fait remonter
j'ai trouvé un pays qui a peur et qui
n'a plus confiance en rien ni en
personne et voyez j'ai même le sentiment
que ça s'est aggravé depuis que j'ai
fait ce Tour de France pourquoi parce
que après la crise économique qu'ils ont
senti sans trop savoir d'où elle venait
mais ils imaginent que ça vient de un
changement de monde dans lequel notre
pays n'a pas
su s'adapter il y a la crise sociale
dont vous me parliez qu'il est meurtri
et maintenant c'est une crise humaine
c'està-dire une relation crise de la
relation entre
entom qui les met dans un état dans le
meilleur des cas de de révolte ça se
manifeste par la révolte oui dans
certains cas je dirais dans les je l'ai
interprété un peu comme ça de très
vieilles de provinces voyez par exemple
la Bourgogne
l'armaniaac ça pas étonnant qu'ils
étaient un peu constitutifs de la France
je trouvais ça en Corse et dans le
Sud-Ouest d'une manière pas tout le
Sud-Ouest qu'est-ce que les gens vous
ont demandé les gens disent d'abord il
faut c'est très comment je devrais dire
il faut faire très attention je
n'abordais jamais personne qui ne me
regardez pas me permettait pas d'aller
en quelque sorte le fioler voyez je ne
mais après j'avais tellement de gens qui
venaent spontanément vers moi que je
n'arrivais même pas à faire face 7h pour
sortir de
Valencienne un lei matin donc ça vous
donne une idée des gens que j'avais ok
donc qu'est-ce qu'il vous fut remonter
alors qu'est-ce qu' me faut remonter
c'est euh
d'abord on vous déteste on déteste quoi
la classe politique onteste les
politiques on les déteste jusqu'à quel
point euh pour certains c'était en vous
haie c'est c'est de la haine et très
vite euh c'est est-ce que vous vous
rendez compte dans quel état vous avez
mis le pays sans qu'il y ait ou que nous
l'ayons vu le moindre débat vous auriez
pu débattre à
l'Assemblée beaucoup mont dit ça ça m'a
étonné d'une manière télévisée et que
vous en débattiez
et ensuite c'est mais d'où vient cette
[__] de dette on est plus endetté
qu'au lendemain de la guerre on paye
maintenant on paye même plus qu'on doit
on paye des montagnes d'intérêt
d'empereur qui qui est paraî-il de
l'argent qui n'existe pas et
euh
l'Europe nous avons cru que vous
construisiez l'espace le plus avancé du
monde grâce à nos acquis sociaux humains
nous sommes des humanistes nous avons
payés par des flots de sang
euh les le rêve d'un continent le plus
vieux apaisé et vivant en bonne harmonie
et vous en avez fait la plateforme la
plus avancée de la finance mondiale
voilà en gros ce qui m dit qu'est-ce que
l'Europe aujourd'hui où nous amenez-vous
vous avez senti les Français trahis ah
oui et doule ureusement et ce qui m'a
frappé c'est d'entendre cela notamment
dans le nord de la France et l'Est j'ai
fait je ne sais combien de mariages pour
vous citer un exemple dans cette bonne
vieille ville de Lille je l'ai connu
pro-européenne je pense qu'il y avait
pas un seul antieuropéen l'histoire et
là j'avais du mal à trouver quelqu'un
qui ne démonta
pas l'Europe alors après tout ça suit
vous me parlez du social là euh est-ce
que vous pensez qu'on est à la veille de
la nuit du 4
août c'est du 4 août est-ce qu'on n'est
pas
1787 est-ce qu'on n'est pas
1900 13 d'une autre
forme est-ce qu'on n
pas al d'ut manière vous en avez parlé
de de de cette
révolte5 vous en avez parlé avec vos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale de
cette révolte qui gronde dans les dans
les campagnes françaises et j'étais
tellement impressionné d'ailleurs après
avoir j'ai commencé par le nord et l'est
de la France j'étais tellement
impressionné euh lorsque je suis arrivé
à Alsace que j'ai décidé d'interrompre
mon tour de France de me rendre à Paris
c'était pas prévu pour rendre compte de
ce que j'entendais au président de
l'Assemblée nationale et au président de
la République quelles ont été rép euh le
président n'a pas pu me recevoir le
président de l'Assemblée m'a reçu mais
j'ai été reçu par un conseiller une
conseillère du président de la
République
euh qui m'a dit bon ne pas être surprise
le président de l'Assemblée nationale
non plus je dis mais moi je comprends
c'est la crise mais est-ce que nous
avons gardé aujourd'hui les moyens de
suivre l'évolution de la France j'ai le
sentiment qu'à tout moment peutil avoir
un accident majeur pour une raison ou
pour une autre est-ce qu'on a les moyens
d'être renseigné parce que j'ai vu et
sans le savoir j'ai décrit l'épisode
breton que j'allais vivre 5 mois plus
tard des patrons qui me disaient si les
ouvriers descendent dans la rue on va
avec eux au pays de la lutte des classes
j'avais jamais entendu ça des
syndicalistes plus remontés que des
coucou euh
des femmes des mères de famille des
chômeurs
toutes sortes de d'hommes et de femmes
que l'on croise habituellement et
monont-il dit on sera informé si ça pète
quelque part par les réseaux sociaux
nous suivons les réseaux sociaux et on y
va vous les
AZ vous les avez sentis on va dire
prendre position sur les les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que pour vous c'est une
nouvelle façon que les gens ont trouvé
de se se coalis autour d'une vraie
démocratie participative et est-ce que
vous pensez que l'Internet procure cet
espace d'échange et de débat alors si
j'ai bien compris les explications qui
m'étaient données euh nos compatriotes
ne ne l'analys pas encore d'une manière
aussi structurée structurée mais il le
voit comme un moyen de se mobiliser et
de se retrouver et de peser sur un débat
dont il se sentent complètement exclus
et sans aucune force ils disent grâce au
réseau par contre nous savons maintenant
que s'il y a quelque chose de fort qui
se dessine quelque part nous saons et
nous pourrons par ce B làà nous
mobiliser comme nous ne pourrions jamais
le faire donc j'ouvre une petite
parenthèse concernant les
réseau vous avez voté contre la loi de
de sur le renseignement quels étaient
vos
motivation l'absence de confiance dans
le fonctionnement et c'est très grave
parce que je suis député je l'oublie pas
un seul instant pour moi c'est une
charge auquelle je suis très attaché
j'en ai rêvé pendant toute ma jeunesse
toute ma mon enfance je n'ai pas
confiance dans le fonctionnement actuel
de l'État et je l'ai déclaré à plusieurs
reprise à l'Assemblée
nationale j'ai plus confiance parce que
je me demande si nous avons encore un
conseil constitutionnel et si oui à quoi
il
sert je mets très gravement en cause le
Conseil d'État parce que quand je vois
que pour la réforme des territoires qui
n pas été du tout préparé sur le terrain
elle n'a pas été faite avec le peuple de
France François mitteran lorsqu'il a
fait la sienne en 1982 l'avait annoncé
et a dit si je suis élu je ferai cette
réforme tout de suite il avait aussi
annoncé c'était pas très populaire la
fin de la peine de mort il a fait des
deux mais tout de suite maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous voulez un président
arrive d'abord il faut qu'il commence
par changer de femme pendant l'été et
ensuite on démarre sur des dossiers
sociétaux et ensuite tout d'un coup on
se trouve euh en train de parler des
conseils généraux des conseils régionaux
que l'on construit un jour que l'
déconstruit le lendemain des régions à
perte de vue et la disparition des
communes ce qui choque et qui touche
beaucoup les Français et bien le conseil
n'a rien trouvé à rire cela j'ai payé
sur mes fondes propres avec un ami 10000
€ une avocate qui a le droit d'ester en
Conseil d'État et je lui ai donné les
arguments qui étaient de deux
ordres le premier c'est que depuis
Clovis dans notre pays s'était institué
une relation quasi charnelle entre
l'homme et le territoire ce qui fait
qu'on a un territoire encore entretenu
comme du papier à musique et la deuxième
c'est la République voulu par la
Constituante et c'est le premier
alinéa égalité pour tous sur l'ensemble
du territoire français et pour la
première fois on allait porter atteinte
à à ces deux notions qui font qui fond
de notre nation c'est-à-dire cette
relation entre l'homme et le territoire
lorsque jeune homme en 1918 ou 1940
était appelé sur le front on ne lui
demandait pas combien il y avait
d'habitants dans son village ou dans sa
ville on lui demandait d'aller
servir jamais en France nous n'avions
décidé de de de d'lire nos représentants
uniquement sur le nombre de leurs
électeurs on tient compte aussi de notre
territoire et de notre patrimoine et
l'autre élément qui a heurté
profondément les Français c'est qu'il
n'y a plus égalité de chances sur le
territoire français parce qu'à partir du
moment vous avez perdu tous les services
publics vous n'avez plus
quelqu'un qui peut vous conseiller vous
aider au nom de l'État voulu par le
peuple mais que vous avez des structures
on va revenir on va revenir sur la la
loi renseignement euh pourquoi cette
opposition à la loi renseignement alors
donc comme je le disais à l'instant déjà
ces deux euh structures c'est deux c'est
pas de structur ces deux grands corps de
l'État me poser problème et puis
j'observe que depuis
un certain nombre d'années il y a trop
de porosité entre la haute fonction
euh d'État et les députés les sénateurs
et les membres du gouvernement certains
continuent à avoir les deux c'est-à-dire
ils peuvent être députés s'ils ont envie
s'inscrireent à l'UMP ou au PS ou
ailleurs enfin dans un parti si possible
qui faitire et il reste au Conseil
d'État
ou il reste à la Cour des comptes où ils
peuvent d'ailleurs continuer à recevoir
un appointement qui n'est pas
négligeable comment voulez-vous dans ces
conditions là d'abord qu'on a une
représentativité du peuple tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui il a particulièrement plus
qu'un ouvrier il y en a pas d' je crois
être un des rares paysan
et c'est un élément à mon avis qui a été
qui est pour moi très important mais sur
le renseignement lui-même il suffit
d'avoir sur soi
un portable pour qu'on sache tout sur
vous on c'est déjà tout sur vous mais je
suis élu depuis 39 an maintenant j'ai vu
l'évolution et je sais qu'aujourd'hui si
on a envie de vous chercher bien on vous
trouve à peu près sur tous les domaines
qu'on veut mais se servir d'une cause
aussi forte et qui a si fortement
interpellé nos compatriotes que les
attentat du 11 janvier pour dire on va
donner des moyens exceptionnel à nos
services secrets et le faire sans aucune
étude d'impact préalable pour savoir de
quelle manière on y parvenait etce que
cela permettait de faire et quel
était le contrôle quelle était l'unité
qui allait procéder au contrôle moi ça
m'a fait peur et alors quand je suis
rentré un petit peu plus dans la lecture
et que j'ai effectivement vu qu' avait
pas d'étude d'impact que c'était une loi
uniquement conçue par l'émotion légitime
que ça l'avait que ça avait occasionné
il y avait de quoi quand il y a 4 ou 5
millions de Français qui descendent sur
la rue c'est beauon est-ce que est-ce
que vous avez vu dans ce texte de loi
une partie réservée aux sanctions en cas
d'abus alors c'est beaucoup plus c'est
là qui est le problème à mon avis c'est
que justement ce n'est pas
codifié
comme tout au moins d'après ce que j'en
ai compris comme c'est cod
pour d'autres aspects pour d'autres
délits on sait que si vous commettez un
viol si vous commettez ça dépend de
circonstan un meurtre si vous ou même
peine de COD de la route on sait quand
même il y a un code d'une certaine
manière tandis que là c'est beaucoup
plus flou donc ce ce texte là ne prévoit
pas de
sanction oui en même temps il il
rappelle pratiquement à tous les
articles que ceux
qui Dét a des informations qui ne
donneraient pas pourrait faire l'objet
de poursuite lourde euh mais il y a plus
même le droit de manifester là je ne
parlais pas au niveau de de ah pardon
excusez-moi je parla au niveau de de
ceux qui emploient les techniques
d'interception en cas de bavu ou en cas
d'abus le texte ne prévoit pas de
sanction ah non non non euh j'ai une
question à vous poser qui est un petit
peu parallèle et connexe à ce sujetl
est-ce que vous pensez que la France
s'est remis en question par rapport à sa
politique étrangère et ne s'est pas dit
notre politique étrangère a généré des
névroses dans le camp d'en face et ce
qu'on en face avec cette conduite
névrotique a généré du terrorisme est-ce
que vous avez vu ça à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est-à-dire une remise en
cause de la politique étrangère
française et des déviances que la
politique étrangère française a pu
conduire sur notre propre territoire
maintenant hélas non je dois dire hélas
parce que c'est très dommageable euh
question très importante par contre j'ai
vu chez nos compatriotes monter
l'inquiétude devant cette
non révision de nos politiques
internationales et nos relations
internationales qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la crise en
Libye je je pense que notre
responsabilité est très lourde dans
cette affaire mais pas qu'en Libye je
pense qu'en Syrie en Irak on a
heureusement évité le pire en
intervenant pas pas directement mais je
crois que dans toute cette une partie du
monde aussi sensible et il ne fallait
pas être prophète c'est le couroup de le
dire pour voir le danger qu'il y avait
potentiellement avec l'immensité des
richesses qui on cours la montagne des
changes qui ont lieu à la fraction de
seconde des changes financier et
l'absence de de de de politique bien
posé le fait d'aller intervenir
là-dedans comme un éléphant dans un
univers de porcelaine il fallait pas
être grand clair pour savoir que ça
allait commettre des dégâts et on a mis
en place d'une certaine manière
nous-même aujourd'hui ceux qui se
comporte comme vous le savez notamment
en Iran mais qui en Iran en Iran
qu'est-ce qu'on a mis en place en Iran
ben en Iran on a mis en irac en Iran
d'abord parce que ça remonte à une
vingtaine d'années je CIS chat voilà du
chat et puis de l'ayatollah après roméie
de roméie euh je pense qu'on a h bon
penser que au fond euh ça allait se
passer plutôt bien et qu'on allait
trouver un contexte qu'un régime avec
basé sur la religion sans la correction
qu'apporte et nous l'avions pourtant
payé très cher dans notre histoire la
laïcité le sentiment de laicité pourvait
poser des problèmes on pourra revenir
sur l'historicité de la crise iranienne
et la
qu même engagé en li pour répondre à
votre question et engagé en Syrie parce
que d'abord qui va
payer nous n soldats d'abord peut-être
comment nos soldats d'abord oui déjà
mais là il y a beaucoup de questions à
se poser en Suisse bon d'abord c'est les
populations qui n'y sont pour rien qui
sont sur ces payslà et qui demandit à
peu près une seule chose c'est qu'on le
fout de la paix voilà et et quand même
c'était pas une
demande quand même excessive
deuxièmement comme
toujours lorsque notre pays ne sait pas
où il
est nos dirigeants font des promesses
Inconsidérées alors bien sûr ils ne
peuvent pas les tenir et comme
toujours c'est souvent le cas hélas avec
des socialistes on se lance dans des
guerres je vous rassure à droite aussi
oui bon je je suis pas
rassuré n'empêche mais bon comme c'est
un gouvernement socialiste il faut quand
même parler du pianiste actuel voilà
donc on se lance dans des guerres sans
aussi comprendre toutes les subtilités
alors bien sûr nous sommes un peu plus
subtil que les Américains mais ça c'est
pas très difficile mais on a perdu alors
que nous avons à mon avis à mes
yeux la meilleure diplomatie du monde
nous la laissons choir comme nous son
choix d'ailleurs nos ambassades des
lieux de de savoir de renseignements
utiles
d'échang mais manière humaine et surtout
contrôlable donc à partir de ce
moment-là on ne sait plus où on va c'est
la course la fuite en avant sans compter
que moi je peux pas je ne veux pas poser
des questions indiscrètees mais je suis
quand même obligé de me poser parfois la
question de savoir par quelles armes ont
été tué
nos soldats ceux de du bleu blanc rouge
quiend de la France oui vous pensez que
ces armes là sont passées déjà dans des
mains de
français qu'on est-ce qu'on a-ce que
certaines n'ont pas été construites chez
nous et je demande même est-ce qu'on
peut aujourd'hui se permettre de vendre
tous ces ces rafales à Bay ami certes
l'Égypte mais il passit de doigt de de
la correctionnelle il y a 2 he hein
et vous avez parlé vous avez parlé de du
commerce des armes vous avez parlé des
États-Unis euh qu'est-ce que vous penser
de la position de Vladimir Poutine euh
par rapport à la liste noire dont je si
M souvir son bon deux députés sont
inscrits sur cette liste
noire je suis pas suffisamment au
courant pour pour vous répondre
honnêtement je je ne de députés français
oui je pas je sais pas si vous aviez si
vous aviez une question à poser à
Vladimir Poutine ce serait
laquelle
mais je lui
demanderai s'il sait vraiment lui-même
ou où il va je lui diraiis je pense que
nous avons été très maladroit nous
occidentaux si je puis dire dans la
politique que nous avons conduit à ton
égard depuis une dizaine d'années n'a
pas envoyé beaucoup de signaux positifs
à l'égard d'un pays qui sortait de 70
années de totalitarisme et
qui qui a perdu qui a perdu quand même
20 millions de ses concitoyens pour nous
délivrer de la menace fasciste nazie au
minimum sans compter ceux de
Staline qui hélas
euh ne se chiffre pas par sa bon allez
changeons de sujet on va parler de du
chômage des marchés financiers qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire sur le chômage
déjà est-ce que est-ce que vos chiffres
sont à jour non ils changent tous les
jours comment voulez-vous il change tous
les jour c'estàdire que la température
augmente et on change le thermomètre ou
on casse le thermomètre vous vous je
sais même plus le thermomètre on le met
en tout cas je suis à l'Assemblée quand
même maintenant depuis pratiquement une
quinzaine d'années je suis incapable de
dire
selon le gouvernement selon les les
indices de calcul combien de de chômeurs
je crois que il y en a 5 millions 5
millions et demi et je ne parle pas de
ce que j'ai rencontré parce que j'en ai
rencontré beaucoup qui ne le sont pas
parce qu'ils ont décroché un bout de de
contrat durée très déterminé ce qui les
sort de la liste mais ça ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui les travailleurs pauvres
exactement et les travailleurs hélas
sans avenir qui se voi eux-mêmes sans
avenir et qui voudrait travailler donc
moi je ne serais pas étonné que nous
soyons
nous soyons pas très loin pour un pays
de 60 millions d'habitants des 100
millions de churs de chômeeurs ou de
personnes qui n'ont plus un travail
régulier et dons sont sûr de retrouver
le lendemain pour être précis vos
préconisations pour retrouver un peu
plus de d'emploi en France ben me semble
que c'est assez ça au moins ne devrait
pas trop hésiter la France est un pays
de vieille tradition la France s'est
développé la France est quand même pays
d'innovation oui et pas de n'importe
quelle innovation nous avons quand même
les innovations nous avons eu quand même
il faut pas faire des cocoric toutes les
lignes mais de là à se diminuer tous les
jours euh on va même jusqu'à réduire la
taille de la France si on pouvait on la
ferait encore plus petite nous sommes la
deuxème façade maritime du monde avec
nos amis ultraarin et bien on est
toujours plus petit mais nous avons
abandonné l'industrie l'industrie que je
sache nous étions très performant et
innovateur dans ce domaine là qui est
devenu l'industrie automobile pour ne
citer qu'un seul exemple je suis passé à
Soo j'ai vu des hommes qui pleuraient de
rage et c'était pas de simples ouvriers
c'était des ingénieurs hautement
qualifiés et disait nous avons été
trahis mais pas maintenant nous sommes
trahis depuis 15 ans et maintenant on
nous offre le choix de devenir chinois
ou allemand vous imaginez PEJ voilà pour
citer un
exemple là les PME
les artisans qui gagnaient de l'argent
il y a 10 ans un plombier on le disait
gagner de l'argent mais moi j'ai des
copains qui étaient plombiers il y a 10
an ilétait pas à pleine
aujourd'hui il se demande de tous les
jours s'ils vont pas être liquidés
financièrement le lendemain matin
pourquoi parce qu'il là aussi baisse de
commande mais de commande tout
simplement dans la construction dans la
construction la préconisation pour
l'agriculture oui qui est terrible dans
une zone de premier pay pense
monantau autant de mal que
vous parce que encore un élément qui
échappe totalement à tout contrôle à
tout contrôle de quelques citoyen que
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
tafta euh tafta je connais moi les
accords les accords transatlantiques ah
oui ah oui oui ah je pensait pas qu'on
nétait réduit à que la France et que la
que la communauté européenne avec tout
ce don nous avons tout ce dont nous
avons dit à nos concitoyens ce nous les
avons convaincus était capable de
s'abaisser à ce niveau-là c'est-à-dire
un accord directement avec les
États-Unis qui pourra être contrôlé
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait que que la
France puisse se faire attaquer par
Philippe marice parce que Philippe
marice trouve que les pratiques
sanitaires de
protection en France bah s'ils sont pas
d'cord ils attaquent la France ça vous
fait c'est scandaleux c'est des
criminels ils tuent
et je peux vous dire que je connais
d'autres cigartiers qui ont d'ailleurs
pignon sur rue puisque
il fa quoi on fait quoi on les attrape
on les met tous en rond d'oignon on va
place de la btille et puis on on
récupère une vieille veuve pour
s'occuper de leur cas dans le retour du
citoyen que j'ai écrit à publié en 2011
avant présidentiel parce que j'espérais
qu'il servira quelque chose j'avais
suggéré que les pays les plus avancés et
plusant le plus dans le monde puisqu'on
fait des G7 des G8 des G10 et j'avais
mis 7 h pays 5 pays dominant plus l'Inde
le Brésil
euh je vais faire attention sur la Chine
parce qu'on sait pas encore mais pour
qu'on se mette d'accord sur les mesures
à prendre sur des trè i de cette ampleur
qui génère autant de malheur et de mort
voilà c'est je pense que la franceat
peut pas s'attaquer elle-même toute
seule mais on prend des on a il est
arrivé quand même qu'on prenne quelques
décisions ensemble ne serait-ce que
celle de faire la paix bon on pourrait
prendre pensez qu'on est en paix à
l'heure actuelle non qu'est-ce que vous
pensez du qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
de du du terme guerre
économique oui dit bien ce ce qu'elle
veut dire mais elle ne dit pas tout elle
ne dit pas
euh la mort qu'elle porte d'abord la
mort de la
conscience la mort d'une certaine idée
de l'humanité euh la mort de la relation
humaine et puis cette souffrance que
chacun porte en lui aujourd'hui quel que
soit d'ailleurs le niveau euh n situ
dans la société mais surtout dans les
catégories les plus modestes car vous
n'avez plus rien
que vous n'entendez plus rien et que
vous savez même pas ce que va devenir
votre fils c'est un bon c'est un bon
vivier de bombe humaine c'est ça ah oui
et alors là c'est pas qui est qui a qui
qui tient la mèche vous comprenez
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des marchés
financiers et des autorités de
régulation des marchés financiers bien
c'est la fin je dirais c'est la
signature d'un long processus qui nous a
dépossédé nous les politiques de tout
pouvoir au nom du peuple ah et vous les
politiques vous vous êtes laissé un
petit peu déposséder c'est un peu
dépossession consentie non oui on a même
aidé nous avons fait les mêmes choix
l'UMP le parti socialiste et Parti du
Centre ont fait à peu près les mêmes
choix depuis une trentaine d'années donc
nous savions très bien que nous
acceptions de ne plus peser sur les
orientations majeures en matière
politique et en France on a fait est-ce
que c'est une
forfaiture je je pense que c'est une
très grande erreur estce que de jugement
des élites forfaiture oui certainement
mais je pense que c'est plus que ça
c'est une
euh c'est une trahison de nos élites
comme nous avons trahi parce que je je
suis pas à Paris je suis pas une bche
colomme je suis dans la politique depuis
des décennies
maintenant de la fin quand même c'est
pour ça qu'onç oui enfin il faut quand
même reconnaître je pas émissionner mon
je bon mais en tout cas c'est pour ça
que je me suis mis à marcher donc on a
décidé de ne plus peser politiquement et
par-dessus le marché on a accepté de
croiser la spéculation je dis pas la
finance parce que la finance c'est un
outil qui pourrait être utile mais la
spéculation qui permet de faire des
montagnes d'or et de détruire les états
avec la technocratie
soviétique la spéculation américaine si
vous voulez mieux avec la technocratie
soviétique au pays des droits de
il Fall fa je dirais la technocratie de
l'école de de Chicago mais on peut on
peut le dire comme ça aussi mais donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ces marchés
financiers si demain je vous donne les
clés de la France qu'est-ce que vous
faites avec les marchés financiers je
pense
d'abord que vous pourrez pas me donner
des clés de la France comme ça et moi je
peux pas non plus les prendre je crois
que ça pose une question fondamentale
c'est la manière dont nous allons faire
ou pasire faire de la politique est-ce
que nous sommes capables de reconstruire
à nouveau
euh une attitude qui soit capable de
nous faire parler ensemble de
réconcilier des hommes de ordinairees de
tout les jours qui n'ont plus le
sentiment d'être des citoyens j'ai
trouvé une institutrice à Alsace qui me
cherchait depuis une quinzaine de jours
j'ai trouvé une femme qui m'a dit avoir
72 m'a dit j'étais une sur de noir de la
République passionnément et je le fêis
d'autant plus que hélas mes deux frères
avaient été de malgré
Nau j'ai appris passionnément à lire
raconter à écrire et maintenant monsieur
le député je ne sais plus qui je suis je
ne sais pas si je suis alsacienne si je
suis française ou si je suis mondiale si
je dépend du FMI ou si je dépendre du
président de la République avec qui je
suis et quand j'en parle à mes de fils
qui ont 45 ans il me disent mais écoute
maman qu'est-ce que ça peut te faire
tout le monde s'en fout mais le pire
c'est quand j'en parle à mes petit fils
que j'adore ils ont 19 et 20 ans ils me
disent écoute mamie qu'est-ce ça peut te
[__] on t'aime beaucoup mais ton monde
est un monde de vieux il nous intéresse
pas ça n'a rien à voir avec nous alors
te casse pas la tête avec ça monsieur le
député est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
qui je suis et rien que dans cette
interrogation d'une femme passionnée de
notre pays d'une femme passionnée de l'
langue française qui connaît le
caractère universaliste de notre pays
qui sait que bien entendu nous avons été
minable parfois quand nous n'étions pas
bien dirigés ni conduit mais que nous
avons été
aussi magnifique à certains autres
moments et que nous
sommes nous avons été détectés choisis
par l'humanité comme ayant une parole
universaliste sur une langue
d'indépendance et de liberté je reviens
je reviens
à ma question si si demain vous avez les
clés de la France par un grand tour de
magie qu'est-ce que vous faites avec le
système financier déjà est-ce que vous
restez dans l'euro est-ce que vous
restez dans l'Europe qu'est-ce que vous
faites pour réguler les marchés
financiers alors d'abord
euh il faut que je le dise de manière
claire et convaincante pour ne pas
pensier seul instant sa langue de vois
de voir si je suis en face de vous je
n'ai pas du tout envie de ça mais je
commence peut-être par une une campagne
électorale où je
m'efforce de reprendre langue avec le
peuple et puis
de découvrir découvrir ensemble quelle
est la véritable situation dans notre
pays sur les questions que vous m'avez
posé sur les questions de la dette sur
les questions
d'absence l'eurau l'Europe et sur la
question de l'Europe bien entendu on
peut pas rester on reste on reste dans
l'Europe ou pas écoutez si moi je décide
tout seul je tombe dans le jeu si vous
avez les Français avec vous et les
Français vous écoutent les Français ont
confiance en vous est-ce qu'on reste
dans l'Europe ah je considère que le
peuple souverain doit décider si le
peuple décide qu' faut sur le More des
choses le dernier que l'on a fait les
Français ont voté OUI et ont voté contre
et nous nous avons trouvé moyen de nous
réunir à Versailles pour
dire oui au nom de notre peuple vous
azité tous de perd ça ça ça nous coûte
très cher aujourd'hui nous le payons
très cher en crédibilité nous payons
très cher cette affaire nous en payons
quelques-un mais cell-là on pas TR cher
oui bien sûr mais en même temps un
référendum ça ne veut rien dire du jour
au lendemain je pense que c'est un
processus qui n' jamais eu lieu tout au
long de la construction européenne nous
ne nous sommes pas tenus informés de ce
que nous faisions et d'ailleurs nous
n'avons pas eu le courage de le faire
nous-mêmes nous les politiques élus par
le peuple nous avons envoyé encore une
fois des hauts fonctionnaires mandaté
comme le maire qui enverrait son
secrétaire de mairie avec d'autres
secrétaires de mairie au cheflieu de
préfecture pendant 10 ans en disant
prépare-moi le département de demain ou
la commune de demain et moi je viendrai
vous vérifier tous les 3 ans et on fera
des déclarations publiques voilà comment
on fonctionne donc bien entendu il y a
une grande grand travail de mise à
niveau qui doit être entrepris et qui
doit se solder par un référendum on a on
a quelques minutes encore je vais vous
poser une question je vais vous lancer
un mot et de but en blanc vous allez me
dire ce qui vous passe par la tête on
essayie démocratie participative ah bien
sûr oui en lui faisant jouer le rôle
qu'elle doit jouer c'est-à-dire il peut
pas y avoir de démocratie sans
participation nous l'avons totalement
oublié mais je pense que nous savons
maintenant de siècles les plus de de
République qui nous a permis d'avoir
aussi une démocratie de représentation
le seul problème c'est qu'il faut être
capable de porter un mandat du peuple
parce que ce n'est pas un métier ce
n'est pas une carrière et de se retirer
si on est battu d'assumer le la défaite
parce que ce queon dit souvent les
Françis vous une anecdote juste vous une
toute petite peti vous les politiques
c'est terrible qu'on nous parle comme ça
quand même non politique vous êtes une
espèce dont on ne se débarrasse jamais
on a le bonheur de vous battre au
législative du mois de mai on a le
bonheur de vousreouver sénateur au mois
de
septembre parfois maire de la commune le
mois de mars qui suit quand ce n'est pas
président du conseil général ou
président du conseil régional vous voyez
que il y a quelque chose qui veut pas
aller dans cette affaire là et que on a
besoin c'est une caste est-ce que c'est
une caste est-ce que c'est une ce de
parasite de parasite non parce que très
sincèrement je pense que l'immense
majorité d'entre nous on le souci de
bien faire par contre c'est une
catégorie qui s'est coupée nous nous
sommes coupés euh du peuple et que le
peuple est un mal en quelque sorte avec
lequel il faut s'accommoder au mieux
pour faire passer nos idées euh
de je vous dis on va changer on va
changer le si je dis Barack
Obama il a fait ce qu'il a pu mais il a
montré les limites d'un président des
États-Unis il pèe pas lourd si je vous
dis euh Vladimir
Poutine à mon avis il
mentre les possibilités d'un chef d'État
qui apprend à composer avec un peuple
qui n'est plus [__] et qui doit à la
fois euh euh se gérer et qui va parler
avec les autres si je vous dis Jeanette
yéen Jeanette yéen qui est la présidente
de la Fed la banque centrale
américaine j'ai pas beaucoup d'affinité
a priori parce que peut-être avec son
son prédécesseur ben ben bernank non pas
davantage parce que je n'ai pas beaucoup
d'affinité avec des organisations et les
leaders de ces organisations dont je ne
connais pas
on une cha YouTube certes sur internet
mais on a des contacts un peu dans dans
la vraie vie si vous parlez
d'organisation si je vous dis le le club
bildelbergs à à quoi ça vous fait
penser excusez-moi je si je vous dis la
Commission
Trilatérale si je dis Ren qui non la
Commission Trilatérale j'ai entendu à
mon amis à mon avis rien qu' vaille
parce que c'est encore le culte du
secret c'est le culte de des sachants à
au plus petit des niveaux moins nombreux
possible qui décid au nom de tous de la
politique à tenir si vous aviez un choix
à faire entre ces deux phrases à ces fou
aveugles ou à ces politiques qui leur
crèvent les yeux assz fou l'aveugle ou à
ces politiques qui leur crèvent les yeux
àe fou l'aveugle atts je coms ass fou
l'aveugle ça veut dire quoi çaz fou
l'aveugle est-ce que les gens sont
aveugles ou est-ce que ce sont les
politiques qui leur crèvent les yeux
euh je pense que c'est hélas les deux
parce que nous pourrions quand même nous
rendre compte il faut pas non plus que
je je je
j'accable les décideurs ou ceux qui
croient décider aujourd'hui parce qu'en
fait nous ne décidons plus de rien je
crois aussi parce que j'ai posé un
certain nombre d'actes que il y a aussi
beaucoup hélas de nos concitoyens qui
préfèrent encore faire ça ou ça et
c'estz vrai aussi parmi vos collègues
médias de la télévision c'est pas de m
du tout et et des et de la presse écrite
parce que j'ai quand même posé des actes
qui étaient des actes forts sur lequels
j'étais très médiatisé j'ai terminé ma
grave de la fin devant 100 télévision
internationale et pas des moindres sur
100 direct à la télévision vous savez
dans quel contexte j'ai terminé mon tour
de France et bien de mois après j'avais
disparu des radars j'ai écrit un livre
bien sûr tout le monde écrit un livre
après un truc après pourir poser un acte
comme celui-là et bien qu'est-ce que
j'ai eu j'ai eu des m gentil et poli de
euh des principaux acteurs de Laurent
Ruquier de de de lu ces intellectuels
médiatiques voilà qui m'ont dit
peut-être qu'on t'invitera la prochaine
mais c'est difficile de parler de ton
livre dans l'état actuel l'an prochain
ben j'ai dit écoutez quand vous voulez
donc vous savez euh il y a peut-être son
peut-être plus nombreux à être dans
l'erreur ce que je crains c'est que cet
aveuglement un peu collectif nous
conduise à à conître ce que nos aïux
n'ont pas pu éviter parce que nous
sommes dans une phase qui ressemble
étrangement vous me demandiez tout à
l'heure quelle année nous étions mais je
ne sais pas moi si on n pas dans une
situation
qui ressemble étrangement au moment où
magéan et Christophe Colom découvrent
les an les Amériques et où les montagnes
d'or qui les amène à déstabilise les
États les royaumes de l'époque seulement
le facteur temps est plus lent les
révolutions interviennent plus tard en
tout cas certains ont obtenu la
possibilité d'organiser les disettes les
ruines les misères et les guerres qu'il
fallait lorsqu'à 1900 lesense vous
pensez que ce qui se passe en ce moment
c'est organisé la dis financière cette
cette austérité cette novelangue cette
novelangue disyée nos concitoyens est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est organisé ou
c'est bien sûr en tout cas ce n'est pas
il n'y a pas le moindre début de combat
qui est mené pour y mettre un terme pas
plus qu'il y en avait à 1900 lorsqu'on a
vu les trains s'est tiré à perte de vue
jusqu'au fond des Amériques jusqu'au fin
des Europes c'estes insectes métalisé
que l'homme venait de construire et ce
liquide de couleur indéfinissable don
quand on pensait l'ensemble du sous-sol
recouvert et bien les mêmes ont fait le
même calcul que vous pensez les luttes
de pouvoir que ça
engendrerai euh cré les plus grands
affrontements et les plus gros
investissements les plus grandes
spéculations jamais eu pour tuer des
hommes voilà et nous sommes dans un
3oème mouvement de mondialisation qui
est un mouvement euh du en grande partie
par les moyens de communication nous
n'avons jamais eu autant de moyens de
communication qu'aujourd'hui et nous
avons aussi peu parlé ensemble entre
nous et je pense que nous courons les
mêmes risques à 1900 cela a débouché
qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur les deux
tragédies qu'est-ce qu'on fait hein Jean
la sal qu'est-ce qu'on fait et bien on
fait une révolte on fait une révolution
on commence à s'organiser on peut plus
s'organiser parce qu'on va être
surveillé ou considéré comme milieu
terroriste on fait quoi on s'organise on
commence à attraper nos députés au feu
rouge on fait quoi non euh moi d'abord
je je suis je suis vous êtes chasseur
aussi
si je me sens comm attend l' euh
français aussi je pense pas oui ah mais
le français mais il faut qu'il soit
guidé aussi hein parce que il faut quand
même pas oublier que nous avons été
quand même de fif collaborateurs pendant
4 ou oui les SCF s'en souvientc bon donc
il faut quand même pas mais à côté de ça
nous avons eu des fulguran qui ont
encore marqué le monde entier et nous
avons permis euh aider donc on fait quoi
on fait une grande
fulgurance je vais vous poser ma
dernière question donc cette dernière
question elle est classique sur notre
chaîne Youtube c'est donner un conseil
aux jeunes
générations donc vous avez l'opportunité
de laisser une bouteille à la mer sur
les réseaux sur Internet cette vidéo
sera pratiquement immortelle laisser un
conseil aux jeunes générations une
bouteille à la
mer prenez votre vie à le corps euh
aujourd'hui vous êtes vous avez la
jeunesse vous avez la force avec vous
vous n'avez pas forcément le savoir mais
il vient moi j'étais mère 21 ans et tout
le monde se demandait qu'est-ce que je
je ferais je le suis toujours 39 ans
après n'attendez pas que pour l'instant
on puisse vous dire ce qu' convient de
faire nous ne le savons pas nous-même
par contre si vous vous mettez en route
vous allez nous redonner le goût et on
peut refaire quelque chose qui n'a
peut-être pas été fait dans notre pays
mais qui a été fait dans d'autres je
peux pas oublié que
Gandi a ouvert la route du sel et fichu
les Anglais qui avait aucune envie de
quitter l'Inde dehor sans une goutte de
sang pratiquement je peux pas oublier
que dans un autre pays terrifiant un
homme a passé 30 ans en prison sans
qu'on sache juste pourquoi alors bien
sûr ce qu'il a fait est un peu remis en
cause parce que le bonheur de humain ne
dure jamais très longtemps mais on peut
connaître au lieu du fracas que mes
paroles pourraient laisser sous-entendre
une période de lumière la plus grande
réserve dont nous disposons notamment
chez les jeunes c'est l'intelligence
c'est celle don nous nous servons le
moins c'est aussi la sagesse chez nos
seigneurs qu'est-ce qu'on fait de nos
seigneurs dès qu'ils ont fini ou même
s'ils ont pas fini terminé ils sortent
du cadre alors que si on leur portait
l'attention qu'on devrait leur porter
ils s'intéresseraiit qu'est-ce qu'on
fait des moyens de communication tels
que les
vôtres la matière grise qu'il faut
acquérir pour s'en servir comment ne pas
s'intéresser beaucoup plus à ces moyens
de communication comment on c'est
intéressé à l'imprimerie à d'autres
moments au télégraphe à d'autres moments
moi je crois que nous avons beaucoup de
possibilités le tout c'est de d'arriver
à convaincre et je pense que ça dans le
cadre émotionnel parce que c'est la
politique c'est aussi de l'émotion que
qu'on faire les campagnes électorales
qu'il faut reprendre langue sur tout ça
en tout cas moi je me suis mis en route
je représente pas grand chose je suis
tout de même encore un député dans
l'exercice de ces fonctions j'ai déposer
des actes je regarde ce que ça donne il
faut convenir pas grand-chose pour
l'instant mais c'est pire que la nuit
d'insomnie je veux terminer là su si
vous permettez les nuit d'insomnie c'est
terrible dire j'ai 60 ans et les quatre
fils de députés que je laisse
aujourd'hui ont moins de chance de
réussir leur vie que les quatre fils de
bergers que mon père a laissé en ce
monde avant de de partir et partir comme
ça
ça me donne tellement mal au ventre que
je peux pas dormir la nuit je me
réveille c'est pour ça que j'ai marché
et c'est pour ça que j'ai envie de
continuer à réfléchir à apportter ma
volonté ma fureur de vivre d'une
certaine manière mais mon bonheur du
printemps la jooix d'être un humain le
plaisir d'être de cette terre le plaisir
d'être vivant pour que ça se fasse d'une
manière différente pour la première fois
en France Jean merci merci à vous
[Musique]